what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel um today I'm at
my parents house and I'm gonna be
showing you um the Taj mashette so when
I was in college and I came home and
there's this big hole in my backyard and
I'm like Dad
what's going on
he said I'm building a shed normally
when when you build a shed like you
think that
you think that it's it's like a a
warehouse where you just have a couple
you know four-wheelers blessing would
you say that is how you would describe
this shed yeah yeah
um so the cool thing about this shed is
that we're gonna use it for um
ideally we're gonna have events here so
we could do like a live show and host
like you know you guys could come buy a
ticket and come to one of these events
um or
you know concerts that sort of thing
like there's a lot of or like a YouTube
we want to do a red pill basketball game
okay hear me out hear me out come on
go
it's half done by the way my dad's been
saying it'll be done for a while
he does gas with me but the big parts
are done okay the big part
so
all right this
is where we walk in okay now this is
gonna be like a kitchen entertaining
area so watch imagine
guys welcome to the show here's your
hors d'oeuvre
here's your here's your shrimp cocktail
watch me watch me over here okay imagine
imagine I'm in here white school episode
imagine what up guys welcome to Wife
School boom I'm chefing it in the
kitchen boom you know maybe even a you
know okay sorry cut that out
no no no no
no no no no no no no
um okay so we go this way
and
I mean these are just like bathrooms
there it's important
um
the big next thing is okay imagine we do
a YouTube Olympics
we bring in all the red pill guys all
the blue pill guys and we say come to
Chicago all right
and hang out
Destiny Let's Bowl
I think he's been talking a lot of
on stream recently so I don't know if
we're on good terms but but regardless
look at we have a bowling alley here
Imagine The Red Pill Olympics
now on top of that to scare off any
liberals because that like obviously you
have to be involved in this
because all the all the Liberals will
think they'll say it'll be the red pill
people but here let me see if there's a
light in there
yeah here okay you can come in it's half
built but a gun range so anyone that
wants to be creepy or try anything we
have a lot of guns here that's my
warning all right but but
look it so we can all the Liberals that
come compete they'll be like oh this is
such a fun day of games and we'll be
like look it if you want to win you
gotta shoot
Olympics baby now yeah so it goes all
the way back boom boom boom boom
you want to shoot blessing
how old is your cameras
listen you're from Africa I know you
shoot
you know you do um
don't they have guns in Africa plus yeah
I was like
I can't imagine if you're able to take
that away oh good luck okay wait hold on
I'm gonna show them this gym and then
I'll show them the other gym
so
during this Olympics right
we're gonna do I know the red pill is
big on like fighting so are you ready
boom boom
number two we'll do a slap contest
I mean maybe some like
but then watch watch you slap
wow
okay here my mother has taken out her
frustrations with her current
Administration
we are Republicans here I don't know
what to tell you guys conservatives
whatever we got so during this bot like
this red pill boxing or whatever boxing
match we do we can maybe even do like a
pull-up contest you want to see me do a
pull-up boom I can't I don't think which
one is a pull-up this one
uh
actually I can't do it
[Music]
squat rack
you know get a little boom you know you
know no one make fun of my form
then we go over here
we could do like how long can you do
cardio
this
does a thing this
okay
[Music]
see that you see the vision blessing
that's it
so it's still um moving from my Fury
this is a special weight they need then
if the whales want to come here
and do some weight loss challenges
boot camp so any any overweight women
that want to apply to lose the weight
because we're not we don't just talk
about the problem we offer Solutions
now I'm addicted to Sugar so maybe I
can't help you with nutrition but I've
been training for 10 years I can help
you trained so you know this is a weight
thingy
what does this do
is this like a stretcher
keep your arms and I'm just curious
oh
oh wait do I sit here
what
I don't understand that okay you can
understand it Leah
no
says you may or may not know I did
play Semi-Pro volleyball and basketball
so I was a better volleyball player you
want to see a couple things
now look it I didn't have the best hands
all right
okay
so you know we don't have the court
the good stuff
[Music]
hold on one second
can you shoot yes I can shoot
Sports were very important growing up
like you're gonna have to yell because
the mic is here
[Music]
growing up Sports were really important
I really felt like I was competing for
my parents love yes based on how we did
in our Sports season
there we go
did you get that no no
you didn't get it nah
foreign
[Applause]
my favorite one was just
[Music]
my biggest thing was I would just
back it up
you can hide under there if life gets
tough
over here
racquetball so boom
oh
I've never played that's how I imagine
it would go
we'll go up here
all right so
this is my dad's future man cave
empty now
but my dad also said he's gonna build us
um if we want to do a show here
he's gonna build us a room over there
it's wall now but
you could also it's dark but you could
see the racquetball too
so if I wanted to annoy him I would do
if I wanted to annoy him and he locked
me out which never happens ever I would
just go in there and be like Dad
Dad Dad I'm here
now
um this is also a room that doesn't
exist
yet
this you could fall down here so oh yeah
don't do that
this is my dad's man cave
so here
I actually it's a garage
here's the second part of
this
oh we already have a lot of it broken
down
hello hey
this is my future bedroom yes
this is my office uh my brother's office
currently but I think that this can be
negotiated no there's no space for
negotiations I see a lot of space
foreign
I see a lot of negotiation
possibilities I see a bed right here
yes but right now it's my brother's
office so it's it's one of the
the sorry
we continue
um I think this is gonna be another
bedroom
I guess I could take this one
I I am moving home you know
my mom says I need to get an apartment
but I prefer this
um another one
empty right
um
then the cool thing is
here is like a little kitchen area I
think that's where they're gonna put the
washer in the dryer
and then
this
kitchen life
oh your slips don't work
well
yeah
so basically this is going to be like a
little house on the shed
it's like Little House on the Prairie
The Little House on the show
um
I do really like this room
so this room yeah
I think I can win it
take me out on the wall I would
that's your TV yes it's actually our
it's our uh it's our board for whatever
dad is in here because we can't see our
monitors so I'm very excited to come
home I think I'll be a great addition to
the family
well you know Eva's gone I'm in
sometimes the good goes out in the bed
comes in
okay that's a bit rude that's a bit rude
you know I'm a delight I'm a delight to
be around
wouldn't be entertaining every once in a
while thank you thank you and do you
play basketball no can we need to get
you learning well playing tomorrow
you're more than welcome to join us oh
really a bunch of the oh yeah let me let
me kick some ass what time at all better
figuring that out probably like six or
something pretty young well they're
gonna go to the casino after
okay well
I don't know we'll see I might have
another I might have oh I might have an
oh guess who messaged me today wait for
it
here it comes
almost there
I'm gonna get the room guys I'm going to
I don't know what they're built oh
that's like a
I'll show you the second watch area yeah
and this is just like boring boy stuff
I don't
know
that's like a saw thingy majiggy
this is the orange thing
this is like you know
Okay so
that's why I'm gonna put my room up
there
the last thing okay blessings somehow
weaseled his way I don't know how he did
it
he keeps weaseling his way into getting
free housing
I don't know how he does it
but he thinks he's gonna do it again
and my answer is no well no no no no
he gets paid well enough to get an
apartment
no okay just somehow weasels his I don't
know how he does it he weasels all right
he weaseld his way into this job right
oh maybe somebody can he said oh
cameraman he's matching in stride for
stride he's run the whole race with a
camera on his shoulder just incredible
he was very talented all right
but two two
then right then
he weasels it doesn't matter
this is the view so ideally I was
thinking these would be box seats so if
you pay x amount of dollars
you can then let's say we did my shows
my two shows a week live from here
you could then pay to go tickets or you
could if you're in the area unlimited
box seats we could give a box for you
and your family this could be your box
show them the Box
yes look how comfortable this is we
could put a little couch up here and you
can be like
ten thousand dollars a year
no a season
these are season tickets
unless you're calling you can just show
up anytime yeah unless you're like Kanye
or someone really important then we'll
just you know accommodate
yay yay he's never gonna come because I
always call him Kanye
it's just it tough to remember you know
that's the shed
um I've already done a house tour on my
channel so if you wanna know what the
house looks like
can I I would like to to bring them to
the playground
Hey Ron you didn't see the playground
well they're the playgrounds over there
they moved it
but we saw the swings
it's all going on the camera
thank you
I really didn't appreciate the space of
this area when I was younger
the grass
oh my dad has a garden over there
I watered it yesterday and then it
rained
trampoline
I want to show them these all right
don't ever get around trampoline Okay
all these people
they get Circle trampolines and they
don't bounce
you see this air
you don't get this
on a circle trip
you don't
we have two
I'm getting nervous
yes
[Music]
all right
anyways guys
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel
let me know what you want to see a tour
of next
uh we've done an office tour done house
tour
done a Shed Tour
and let me know what interesting video
ideas could you come up with let me know
what you guys think
in the comments like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel I'll
talk to you next time